en mi más digamos humilde opinión la
reacción bioquímica más importante
especialmente para nosotros es la
respiración celular que vamos a notar
esto es la respiración celular y la
razón por la cual digamos me siento muy
seguro de esto es porque es digamos la
forma en la que obtenemos energía a
partir de lo que comemos digamos de
nuestro combustible verdad o si queremos
ser un poco más específicos obtenemos la
energía de la glucosa y al final del día
digamos la mayor parte de lo que comemos
o al menos todos los carbohidratos
verdad terminan como glucosa y en vídeos
futuros voy a hablar de cómo obtenemos
esta energía por ejemplo también de
grasas o de proteínas pero la la
respiración celular digamos no nos
permite o digamos ir de la glucosa de la
glucosa y a partir de la glucosa obtener
energía
no tenemos energía a partir de la
glucosa y por supuesto también tenemos
otros subproductos verdad y para hacer
un poquito más específico es verdad
déjenme escribir la reacción química
aquí tendremos la reacción química por
ejemplo martín vamos a partir de la
fórmula química de la glucosa que es c6
verdad es decir tenemos 6 átomos de
carbono h 12 que son 12 átomos de
hidrógeno y 6 átomos de oxígeno entonces
tenemos es 6 h 12 o 6 esto de aquí es
justamente la glucosa esto es la glucosa
y además hay que agregar digamos 6 moles
verdad si tenemos aquí un molde glucosa
hay que agregar 6 moles de oxígeno
gaseoso y digamos como una digamos una
simplificación muy grande que hacemos a
todo el proceso de la respiración
celular de hecho vamos a observar en los
próximos vídeos que uno puede
complicarse en estos procesos en este
mecanismo tan complicado
se puede no complicar tanto como sea
posible verdad y digamos al menos a
grandes rasgos verdad
digamos podemos simplificar este proceso
simplemente como si tuviéramos un molde
glucosa 6 moles de oxígeno gaseoso
verdad y obtenemos a través de la
respiración celular de este proceso de
la respiración celular y lo voy a
escribir aquí aquí vamos a digamos a
basarnos
la respiración celular es un mecanismo y
a partir de este mecanismo obtenemos lo
siguiente obtenemos 6 moles de dióxido
de carbono y obtenemos 6 moles de agua
verdad pero no sólo eso digamos esta es
una parte importante pero yo creo que la
parte más importante aquí es que
producimos energía entonces vamos a
tener energía producida y de hecho esta
es la energía que puede ser utilizada
para digamos hacer cierto tipo de
trabajos como calentar nuestros cuerpos
o digamos generar impulsos eléctricos en
nuestro cerebro así digamos nos nos
brinda energía del mecanismo de la
respiración celular nos brinda energía
especialmente para todas las necesidades
de un cuerpo humano y por supuesto esto
no es únicamente para humanos verdad
también puede ser para otro tipo de
organismos muy bien y cuando decimos
energía verdad cuando estamos hablando
de la energía tú podrías decir oye en
otro vídeo que no
que no simplemente dijiste que el atp es
la digamos la moneda energética de la
célula y entonces nosotros decíamos que
el atp es la moneda energética de los
sistemas biológicos verdad y entonces tú
podrías decir oye parece ser entonces
que más bien la glucosa es nuestra
moneda digamos energética verdad y hasta
cierto punto las dos respuestas serían
correctas pero pero para ver un poquito
de cómo es que en realidad digamos las
dos respuestas pueden ser correctas
digamos el proceso de la respiración
celular si produce energía directamente
pero esta energía esta energía que
estamos produciendo en esta reacción
química se utiliza para producir dos
cosas por un lado vamos a producir calor
y por otro lado vamos a producir 38 atp
38 atp o al menos eso es lo que digamos
varios libros de texto dicen verdad
libros de texto dicen que se producen 38
atp y digamos pueden ser utilizados por
las células para digamos contraer
músculos o generar impulsos nerviosos o
hacer lo que sea necesario digamos
crecer dividirse o cualquier otra
necesidad de la célula así que realmente
la respiración celular verdad decimos
que produce energía pero esto digamos
así nada más no es del todo cierto
verdad en realidad es el proceso que
toma digamos mediante el cual toma
glucosa verdad y produce atp se produce
atp y quizás con algo de calor y algunos
subproductos verdad todo esto esto no es
del todo malo verdad digamos es bueno
obtener calor alrededor digamos
necesitamos estar razonablemente
calientito es verdad para que nuestras
células puedan operar correctamente así
que todo el punto digamos de este
mecanismo es ir de la glucosa verdad ir
de la glucosa obtener nuestros atp es
que según los libros de texto son 38
porque entonces esta energía podríamos
también pensarla como nuestros nuestros
38 atp es verdad en esencia por cada
molécula de glucosa vamos a obtener 38
moléculas de atp y eso es lo que dicen
los libros de texto ahora en realidad
esto es digamos en circunstancias
ideales que vamos a producir 38 atp yo
estaba leyendo un poco antes de hacer
este vídeo y en realidad depende de la
eficiencia de la célula verdad para
poder realizar la respiración celular
pero probablemente sea más bien del
orden de entre 29 y 30 atp hay una gran
variación aquí pero bueno digamos las
digamos los científicos todavía están
estudiando esta idea pero en esencia
todo esto de la respiración celular se
trata de convertir una molécula en
glucosa y obtener 38 atp es verdad ahora
en los próximos vídeos vamos a ir
digamos separando todas estas ideas todo
este mecanismo en sus partes que lo que
lo constituyen verdad y voy a introducir
qué
todas estas partes de este mecanismo
verdad para que te des una mejor idea de
cómo funciona toda la respiración
celular pero vamos a ir mencionando
algunas algunas de estas partes la
primera de ellas es la glucólisis muy
bien voy a anotarlo aquí la primera
parte es la glucólisis
la glucólisis muy bien que literalmente
significa digamos cómo separar la la
glucosa muy bien así que por ejemplo
esta parte la parte gluco verdad de la
palabra glucólisis significa glucosa se
refiere a la glucosa mientras que lee si
es verdad la parte lisis significa
digamos como como romper o separar
cuando hablábamos de la hidrólisis
significa va a utilizar agua para romper
una molécula la glucólisis significa que
vamos a estar rompiendo digamos la
glucosa o separando la glucosa y digamos
en el caso de que te interesa en el
origen de las palabras verdad la
etimología la palabra glucosa voy a
descomponer la aquí verdad
la palabra glucosa en realidad proviene
en parte de una palabra griega verdad
esta parte glub glub verdad significa o
más bien proviene de una palabra griega
que se refiere a lo dulce
a luz dulce mientras que la terminación
osa es la que le damos siempre a todas a
todos los azúcares verdad entonces esta
de aquí es la terminación que le damos
por ser un azúcar y uno pensaría que
quizás es un poco redundante decir que
hay azúcar es dulce es verdad pero en
realidad puede también haber digamos
azúcares que no son dulces por ejemplo
la lactosa que es la que se encuentra en
la leche puede ser un poco dulce pero
cuando de hecho digerimos la lactosa la
convertimos en una en un azúcar que en
realidad si es luz dulce pero pero no
necesariamente de inicio tienen que
saber dulces verdad como por ejemplo la
glucosa o la fructosa pero bueno eso fue
sólo un paréntesis verdad el primer paso
de la respiración celular es la
glucólisis muy bien dice que significa
que implica que vamos a separar oa
romper la glucosa y ahora déjame
mostrarte cómo es que se ve realmente la
glucosa
tengo arriba una imagen de lo que es la
glucosa y podemos ver que en efecto
tiene 6 átomos de carbono verdad aquí
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 átomos de carbono y
podemos observar que en realidad tiene
como una especie de estructura de anillo
verdad así que tenemos nuestros 6 átomos
de carbono podemos observar que hay 6
átomos de oxígeno 1 2 3 4 5 6 y luego
estas pelotitas azules verdad en
realidad son nuestros hidrógenos muy
bien esos son nuestros hidrógenos y así
es como se ve en realidad la glucosa
pero este proceso de la de la glucólisis
verdad déjenme regresar aquí abajo el
proceso de la glucólisis digamos y
empezamos con nuestra cadena voy a
ponerlo como una cadena verdad
digamos tenemos nuestra cadena de 6
átomos de carbono verdad y esto lo hago
para fines de lo que quiero explicar ya
vimos que en realidad se ve más bien
como una especie de anillo verdad tiene
de hecho también algunos
hidrógeno si algunos oxígenos hay unidos
a esta cadena verdad pero esencialmente
tiene como esta columna principal de
carbonos y lo que vamos a hacer es
separar esa columna de carbonos en dos
verdad vamos a separarlo en dos partes
en dos partes que tienen tres carbonos
cada uno y recordemos que por supuesto
aquí también hay otros átomos unidos no
sé de hidrógenos oxígenos pero en
esencia hemos separado esta columna
principal de carbonos en otras dos
digamos en otras dos partes con tres
carbonos cada uno verdad y los digamos
otras cosas que están unidas ahora cada
una de estas moléculas que tienen tres
átomos de carbono se les conoce como
piruvato y vamos a entrar en más detalle
sobre los piratas y este proceso en otro
vídeo pero la glucólisis digamos por sí
mismo genera bueno quizás deberíamos
anotarlo de esta forma la glucólisis en
realidad necesita
se citados a tps para poder llevarse a
cabo 2 atp y además genera genera 4 atp
es entonces si nosotros hacemos el
balance neto verdad si hacemos el
balance podemos observar que tenemos 2
atp en total que tenemos 2 atp y esta es
la primera etapa de la respiración
celular verdad y lo importante en quizás
que podemos mencionar aquí es la
ausencia de oxígeno en realidad este
proceso no requiere de oxígeno y como ya
te lo mencioné haré todo un vídeo sobre
la glucólisis en un futuro estos
subproductos que tenemos por aquí verdad
en realidad se modifican un poquito y
después entran a algo que conocemos como
el ciclo de krebs aquí van a entrar a
algo conocido como el ciclo de krebs y
quizás debería utilizar otro color
utilizar amarillo estos subproductos
entran al ciclo de krebs que es otro
mecanismo verdad y este mecanismo por si
mismo podríamos pensar que produce 2 atp
es muy bien produce 2 atp es por su
cuenta y esto es digamos algo
interesante verdad porque también hay
otro proceso que podríamos decir que
ocurre después del ciclo de krebs aunque
sabemos que en la célula todo está
rebotando y todo está digamos
difundiéndose en la célula verdad pero
bueno se considera que esto ocurre
después de la glucólisis y del ciclo de
krebs y algo que hay que mencionar antes
de pasar al siguiente paso es que el
ciclo de krebs si requiere oxígeno sirve
si requiere oxígeno muy bien este ciclo
de krebs requiere oxígeno y solo para
ser claros en realidad la glucólisis
este primer proceso proceso digamos no
requiere oxígeno no se necesita el
oxígeno y de hecho vamos a notarlo la
glucólisis no necesita oxígeno
mientras que el ciclo de krebs si
requiere del oxígeno verdad o podríamos
pensar que la glucólisis por no
necesitar oxígeno es un proceso
anaerobio y quizás deberíamos ser más
ordenados en esta parte vamos a notarlo
de esta forma nosotros tenemos la
glucólisis aquí tenemos la glucólisis
verdad este es un proceso que es
anaerobio
pero obvio es decir no requiere de
oxígeno para poder llevarse a cabo
verdad y quizás sea esté familiarizado
con la idea del ejercicio anaeróbico
verdad que significa aerobio verdad qué
significa esta parte la idea por ejemplo
del ejercicio aeróbico es que necesita
respirar muy fuerte verdad porque
necesitas mucho oxígeno para hacer
ejercicio aeróbico así que cuando
estamos hablando de un proceso anaerobio
verdad significa que no necesitamos
oxígeno aeróbico significa que necesita
oxígeno anaeróbico significa lo
contrario que no requiere del oxígeno
así que la glucólisis es un proceso
anaerobio y también parte importante es
que produce 2 atp
en total verdad en total
muy bien tenemos una producción de 2 atp
en total y luego si nos vamos por
ejemplo al ciclo de krebs el ciclo de
krebs sería como nuestro siguiente paso
verdad el ciclo de krebs ciclo de krebs
voy a escribir lo mejor el ciclo de
crepes
y lo tenemos este sí es un proceso
aerobio este es aerobio y también
tenemos una producción de 2 atp es muy
bien tenemos una producción de 2 atp por
supuesto entre la glucólisis y el ciclo
de krebs hay un digamos breve preámbulo
aquí pero vamos a entrar en detalle
digamos de este punto en el futuro si lo
importante aquí es que el ciclo de krebs
es aerobio y tiene 2 atp y luego del
ciclo de krebs hay una parte que
francamente cuando yo lo aprendí por vez
primera verdad
en realidad esto me confundió muchísimo
pero bueno solo vamos a ponerlo en el
orden en el que tradicionalmente está
escrito verdad después del ciclo de
krebs tenemos algo que se le conoce como
el digamos la cadena de transporte de
electrones es la cadena
y transporte de electrones
de electrones muy bien y esta parte es
muy importante porque después de la
cadena de transporte de electrones
tenemos la formación de 34 atp es que si
podemos darnos cuenta es como la mayor
producción de atp es que vamos a tener
en todo el proceso de la respiración
celular y esto es importante porque
también es un proceso aerobio muy bien
requiere también de oxígeno para
llevarse a cabo así que como podemos ver
si no tuviéramos oxígeno si las células
no estuvieran obteniendo suficiente
oxígeno podríamos podríamos producir un
poquito de energía verdad aquí podríamos
producir un poquito de energía por estos
2 atp de la glucólisis verdad pero una
vez que ya tenemos suficiente oxígeno
verdad podríamos empezar a producir más
atp es verdad y se debe al ciclo de
krebs y a la cadena de transporte d
electrones muy bien ahora cuando nos
empezamos a quedar sin oxígeno verdad
entonces todo este procedimiento no
puede llevarse a cabo de forma adecuada
y lo que ocurre es que algunos de estos
subproductos de la glucólisis verdad en
vez de entrar al ciclo de creerse entran
a un proceso paralelo llamado
fermentación así que lo voy a escribir
por acá entran a un proceso llamado
fermentación
está muy bien para algunos organismos
este proceso de fermentación toma
algunos de los subproductos de la
glucólisis y literalmente producen por
ejemplo alcohol verdad al día y de hecho
parte del alcohol que la gente consume
viene de ahí y se le conoce a esto como
la fermentación alcohólica para nosotros
digamos como seres humanos nosotros no
producimos alcohol sino por ejemplo
nuestros músculos no no producen el
alcohol en realidad lo que producen es
el ácido láctico que voy a ponerlo
nosotros como seres humanos producimos
ácido láctico muy bien y esto por
supuesto es porque somos humanos ok en
otros organismos puede haber otro tipo
de producción es verdad por ejemplo esto
quizás sea válido para también otro tipo
de mamíferos pero por ejemplo también
tenemos la levadura verdad la levadura
es lo que se utiliza para producir
cierto tipo por ejemplo de pan y lo que
ocurre es que
hay una fermentación alcohólica es decir
la levadura produce al alcohol
fermentación alcohólica
muy bien pero bueno todo este proceso de
la fermentación es justamente cuando no
disponemos de el oxígeno necesario
verdad y de hecho es el ácido láctico el
que por ejemplo cuando hacemos mucho
ejercicio verdad y no obtenemos
suficiente oxígeno entonces nuestros
músculos se empiezan a doler y eso es
porque se empieza a formar el ácido
láctico
pero bueno toda esta es una cuestión
paralela verdad sí sí digamos tuviéramos
suficiente oxígeno entonces podemos
movernos al ciclo de krebs que es un
proceso aerobio verdad obtenemos
nuestros dos antes y luego pasamos a la
cadena de transporte de electrones y
producimos nuestros 34 atp es muy bien
que en realidad es la mayor producción
de atp es que va a ocurrir en la
respiración celular
ahora vamos a digamos mencionar esto
como de forma paralela pero pero
mientras estos dos procesos se llevan a
cabo la glucólisis y el ciclo de creer
es verdad también se van a producir otro
tipo de moléculas
estas dos partes de en estas dos
reacciones digamos la glucólisis y el
ciclo de krebs verdad en estos dos
justamente vamos a estar tomando
constantemente una molécula que se llama
enea de simplemente lo voy a llamar como
nada verdad en realidad es nada más
y vamos a añadir hidrógenos para formar
lo que conocemos como nada h
muy bien
y lo que realmente ocurre es digamos por
cada molécula de glucosa 10 nada verdad
10 de estos no se convierten en nada h
muy bien así que en realidad eso es
parte de lo que lleva digamos todo en la
cadena de transporte de electrones y
vamos a hablar más a detalle de cómo es
que esto ocurre y cómo es que de ahí se
obtiene energía y cómo es que esta es
una reacción de oxidación vamos a hablar
de qué es lo que se está oxidando qué es
lo que se está reduciendo pero sí quería
mencionarlo estos dos procesos verdad no
solo no sólo están produciendo sus 2 atp
es en cada uno de estos en cada una de
estas etapas verdad sino que también
están produciendo verdad de forma
combinada 10 nada h es verdad y digamos
que además cada uno de ellos produce atp
digamos 3 atp es en una situación ideal
ahora bien por otro lado también están
haciendo algo similar a otra molécula
verdad que es
paz muy bien efe a de que de hecho es
bastante similar verdad y lo que ocurre
aquí es que está produciéndose paz h2
muy bien es algo digamos de un proceso
bastante similar verdad ahora yo sé que
todo esto es bastante complicado pero
vamos a hacer vídeos de esto en el
futuro lo importante digamos aquí es
recordar que la respiración celular
consiste principalmente en tomar glucosa
verdad y digamos la energía que está en
la glucosa y re empaquetarla en forma de
lo que sabemos que dicen los libros de
texto que son 38 atp es muy bien así que
si estás haciendo un examen es un muy
buen número para escribirlo verdad en el
examen y en realidad tiende a ser un
número mucho más pequeño verdad como del
orden de 30 atp es verdad y por supuesto
también va a producir calor de hecho
gran parte de estas reacciones van a
producir calor pero
los 38 atp que estamos generando en
realidad se generan a lo largo de tres
etapas verdad que hemos puesto aquí
abajo la primera de ellas es la
glucólisis que en donde estamos
partiendo a la glucólisis en dos verdad
y generamos atp pero digamos también
parte importante de esto es que estamos
generando algunos nada es verdad que
serán utilizados después en la cadena de
transporte de electrones verdad luego
estos subproductos digamos se van a
separar más y esto será en el ciclo de
krebs verdad que también va a producir 2
atp es verdad y también va a producir
varios nada es verdad y todos esos
nadies van a ser utilizados en la cadena
de transporte de electrones verdad para
producir la mayor parte de nuestra
moneda energética que son 34 atp